wie geht s wohl boris becker heute nach
der vierten nacht hinter gittern in
england und wie geht's seinen
angehörigen unter anderem seiner
freundin lily allen das alles kann uns
jetzt bild live show chefin giannina
cash erzählen und janina ja die vierte
nacht ich habe es gesagt und ja die
vierte nacht auch für seine freundin
ohne boris er allein im knast sie
alleine in der wohnung ohne ihren
liebsten und es haben uns fotos erreicht
fotos von lillian zum ersten mal seit
dem urteil denn sie war er untergetaucht
und hier sehen wir sie immer noch eine
sonnenbrille tragen der blick gesenkt
ich glaube man muss ihr gar nicht in die
augen gucken um zu sehen dass es ihr
nicht gut geht also sie verzieht im
prinzip keine miene die mundwinkel nach
unten hier steigt sie jetzt aus dem auto
ausgeht einkaufen und was mir natürlich
sofort aufgefallen ist die käppi die
käppi ist von puma die tragetasche die
sie um trägt diese das ist so eine
beutel tasche auch von puma sondern auch
die schuhe sind von puma und boris
becker ist seit jahren das
aushängeschild von thomas dass es sein
sponsor er arbeitet seit vielen vielen
jahren mit puma zusammen auch puma
erhält ihm auch die treue muss man sagen
dürfen der ganzen auch jetzt noch trotz
der ganzen schlagzeilen das heißt ein
klares statement ein klares bekenntnis
für ihren boris komplett gekleidet in
puma trotzdem aus sicht einer frau kann
ich sagen wenn ich das sehe dieser
gesenkte blick diese traurigen
mundwinkel auch gekleidet in schwarz
oder schwarz die farbe der trauer dass
es ihr nicht gut geht das spürt man
durch das bild hindurch
dann die große frage die wir uns ja seit
tagen gestellt hat da ist noch der
zwölfjährige sohn amadeus wie wird man
ihm es sagen und wann wird man ihm ist
uns haben die information erreicht dass
willi es ihn mittlerweile mitgeteilt hat
willi hat ihn gestern gesagt dass sein
vater im gefängnis sitzt amadeus soll
das sehr tapfer aufgenommen er war
natürlich aufgewühlt hat jetzt wie jedes
kind viele viele fragen er war aber er
hat nicht geweint gestern war feiertag
in england das heißt amadeus hatten
schulfrei lilly hat dann ein paar
freunde eingeladen darunter unter
anderem eine psychologin die amadeus
auch schon lange kennt also ein gutes
familiäres friedvolles umfeld um ihnen
diese ihm diese doch wirklich traurige
und für einen kleinen jungen ja auch
dramatische nachricht zu überbringen
was unsere unserem reporter john
puthenpurackal dazu holen thomas ich hab
doch noch was mitgebracht warte mal kurz
ich muss mich immer wirken weil guck mal
david card kitkat hier
cookies mitgebracht und ich habe rafa
keks mitgebracht und wenn sie sich jetzt
fragen ob ich thomas messen möchte weil
er so schlank und rank ist oder ob du
werbung machen oder ob ich werbung
machen wirst du schnell weg nein
tatsächlich ist dass die süßigkeiten
liste aus once were also auf aus dem
gefängnis wo boris becker sitzt wir
haben exklusiv da hat unser reporter
john puthenpurackal besorgt die liste
der süßigkeiten bekommt die die insassen
kaufen dürfen und die würde ich ihnen
gerne einmal zeigen hier sehen wir sie
abfotografiert und da stehen unter
anderem genau diese süßigkeiten drauf
also zum beispiel cadbury milk fingers
kosten 1 euro 53
dann haben wir hier chocolate cookies
70 cent die packung dann haben wir noch
andere leckereien zum beispiel die eben
erwähnten java cakes diese leckeren
weichen kekse mit orange drin ein euro
19 dann haben wir noch mit schokolade
für einen euro 19 und das eben genannte
kit card im fünfer pack für 1 eur 19
jahren das kann der bobbele wenn er
denkt geld übrig hat sich kaufen wenn er
mal heißhunger auf schokolade hat oder
nervennahrung braucht gut dann jetzt
aber zu john kucera ka nach london der
uns sagen kann
wie läuft das ab die wie funktionieren
so zahlt man mit kreditkarte zahlt man
in bar wo er der boris das geld bekommt
er etwas jeden tag wie sie daraus
ja jeder häftling hat ein konto auf dem
eben geld es was er eben vorher
eingezahlt hat oder überwiesen bekommen
hat und man muss sich das so vorstellen
diese süßigkeiten die janina gezeigt hat
die werden alle durch ein cantine
service geliefert das heißt durch eine
art lieferservice die häftlinge bekommen
nach meinen informationen täglich einen
zettel unter die den türspalt geschoben
dort ist diese liste die wir gerade
gesehen haben und dort können sie
ankreuzen was sie denn gern davon haben
möchte darauf ist damit keine schokolade
nicht nur schokolade sondern auch
hygieneartikel oder anderes und das wird
dann nach der bestellung eine woche
später wenn alles gut läuft zu den
häftlingen geliebter gian wie muss man
sich das jetzt vorstellen bekommt boris
becker jetzt taschengeld
quasi im stehen pro woche aktuell zehn
bis zwanzig pfund zur verfügung die er
im gefängnis ausgeben darf entweder zum
telefonieren oder zum einkaufen von
diesen bietern die wir gerade besprochen
haben er kann da dabei von einem konto
zugreifen also das quasi von einem konto
abbuchen darauf darf maximal 900 pfund
sein und von dem darf für zehn bis
fünfzehn bis zwanzig pfund pro woche
ausgeben er wird ja auch früher oder
später
arbeiten müssen im gefängnis ist es ja
auch ganz normal und sich da auch geld
verdienen können
absolut also es ist nun aktion aber
davon auszugehen dass boris becker in
den nächsten vier fünf wochen erstmal
nicht arbeiten wird sondern die meiste
zeit in seiner zelle verbringen wird
einfach aus dem grund dass gefängnisse
über ist überfüllt aber wenn er eine
arbeit einer arbeit nachgehen würde im
gefängnis dann würde er dafür auch geld
bekommen und das dann entsprechend von
seinem konto aus dann auch ausgeben
dürfen wir haben es gerade gehört janina
hat uns erzählte amadeus weiß inzwischen
bescheid weißt du schon welche
möglichkeiten denn boris hat jetzt
beispielsweise mit seinem sohn zu
telefonieren wenn er das möchte
aktuell darf er einmal pro woche
telefonieren
maximal fünf minuten
es wird eben auch von seinem konto
abgebucht wenn er mit ihm telefonieren
möchte muss er das vorher anmelden diese
gespräche werden aufgezeichnet und nach
meinen informationen hat ein gespräch
bisher noch nicht stattgefunden
er hat bisher ein telefonat geführt und
das wird aber demnächst sicherlich ganz
nahe zukunft auch stationen pokal aus
london wer den prozess für uns
beobachtet hat er eben entscheidende
moment im gerichtssaal war als die
verurteilung kam und er dabei war als
boris becker in einem weißen gefangenen
transporter ins gefängnis gebracht wurde
vielen dank john
thomas ich frag mich ob zehn bis zwanzig
und reichen wenn man dann auch raucht
wir haben ja gestern gehört wie teuer
zigaretten sind und der schwarzmarkt der
ist da ja auch ganz groß zehn pfund pro
woche 20 von pro woche also und dann
kostet ja so ein ding schon ein euro 19
oder
ja ich frage mich auch welchen job er
wohl machen würde wenn er denn einen
machen kann da gibt es viele
möglichkeiten küche wäscherei
keine ahnung was guckst du na ja ich
würde ihm wünschen dass er irgendwas
sportliches machen kann also dass er
irgendwie in irgendeiner form die
menschen die vielleicht lust haben sich
sportlich zu betätigen die von animieren
tennistraining gibt es leider nicht dort
aber es findet sich ja vielleicht was
anderes war als coach war immer gut er
hat mit djokovic wahnsinniger erfolge
gefeiert das würde man ihm doch
irgendwie wünschen dass er diese
erfahrung nutzen kann die auch an die
häftlinge weitergeben kann da war immer
der beste und dann wird er immer der
beste sein das würde ich ihm gehören auf
jeden fall und dir schenkt ich jetzt am
ende der sendung noch was möchtest du
kitkat oder kekse am günstigsten
was uns am günstigsten bekommt sie hier
die wogen sie hier die orange gerade
dann wird du dich von fleisch fällt ganz
herzlichen dank sehr
großzügig